o que eu vim aqui comentar com vocês
como foi mencionado eu sou a presidente
de de algumas empresas
então vocês podem fazer idéia de quanto
a mulher
hoje ela é requisitada ela precisa ser
responsável é por de trás de mim quando
eu digo por detrás porque eu sou é a
presidente então tem minha família e
meus filhos netos
são mais de 1.600 funcionários diretos
daí tem mais familiares desses
funcionários
então quando você mesmo hoje o mundo
como está globalizado
você fica pensando quando tramp da
qualquer comentário lá o mercado já
vacinou já dá toda aquelas associações é
o chinês lá falar alguma coisa você já
mexe com o mercado a qualquer coisa
política interna do brasil méxico
cenário nosso qualquer problema de clima
mexe no nosso mercado
então onde a gente atua no agronegócio é
concessionária se a transportadora em
qualquer setor da economia se a
construção que não é nossa área mas
vocês sabem que interfere
então vocês vêem quanto para o
empresário hoje sobreviver ou se manter
e de principalmente continuar crescendo
porque eu sempre digo se você ficar
parado
você já ficou para trás porque os demais
vão seguindo então a gente não pode
parar
a gente tem que continuar a gente tem
que ter pessoas nós precisamos ter
pessoas boas e confiáveis pessoas leais
à família que dá sustentação então é
tudo isso faz parte para que você tenha
que nem a nossa amiga falou uma
estrutura que dê sustentação para que a
gente possa continuar
eu acho que deus eu sou muito temente a
deus
eu acho que deus a cada um de nós ele
dar uma missão aqui na terra
eu vejo que tem muita gente por ali que
pensa que eu acho que não vai morrer
principalmente político é fazer tanta
coisa ou contanto que eles pensam que
não vai acontecer nada com eles
eu tenho essa certeza que a gente tem um
tempo que a gente nasce ea gente tem o
trânsito aqui pra gente fazer as coisas
no quando nós vamos prestar contas
quando nós vamos dar tchau e eu quero
que quando chegar esse momento o que
deus me incumbiu o que ele me deu de
competência o que ele me deu de
patrimônio para que eu possa desenvolver
empregar pessoas que pessoas possam
estudar constituir família viajar com
pra cá que elas sejam felizes
eu estou feliz porque meu deus e
incumbiu ele me deu essa capacidade eu
tenho que desenvolver
eu não quero chegar lá naquele dia e
deus é vanda e todo esse talento eu
tenho esse patrimônio o que você fez
gols e enterrou não eu tenho que cumprir
e ele me capacita todo tinha eu preciso
disso eu rezo pela manhã em reação à
noite reza no caminho eu rezo de casa
vendo pra fag houve a onde estou indo no
quase não ouço mais rádio porque a gente
tem que tem momentos que você tem que
fazer reflexão
então isso tudo é hoje hoje minha
família meu marido está doente já faz 11
anos que está afastado dos negócios que
está com o time está totalmente já bem
não fala nunca mais há mais de seis anos
meus filhos já estão todos dentro da
sucessão cada filho já tem autonomia
todos já estão dentro da vocação de cada
um e eu já fiz tudo isso então hoje eu
já estou bem mais tranquila mas vocês
vão ver a minha história não foi nada
fácil por isso que digo deus foi
detalhando foi me preparando pra que eu
pudesse chegar nesse momento e dessa
forma que faça a passaria pra mim não
faz ou isso é na verdade então aqui é
onde eu nasci
se alguém é gaúcha que conhece a região
do alto uruguai
é é bem próximo de da barragem do
uruguai ele e tá né
não não quilômetros então assim essa
região ali ela era assim muito muito ela
é muito montanhosa a nossa casa tinha
uma montanha na frente uma montanha trás
e era assim tipo 1
a gente fala várzea é uma região plana
em baixo a senhora que tinha casa era o
único lugar plano que tinha na região
então ali eu eu nasci ali nós ficamos
ali as crianças até aos nove anos a
infância pra mim ela foi muito
importante na minha formação
por isso que eu digo hoje os pais não
têm a consciência de quanto é importante
a companhia está presente na na educação
dos filhos
não digo uma quantidade que ele falou
mas a qualidade da atenção então é meu
pai ele teve assim minha mãe era
professora então ela ficava meio período
fora de casa e meu pai era agricultor
mas além de agricultor ele tinha ele era
azul e cultores ele tinha uma granja de
suínos e ele é produzir só matrizes de
suining o que matrizes de suínos
ele é quando uma a porta a leitora
ganharmos leitãozinho por exemplo
ganhava 10 11 12 7 eles redirecionavam
aqueles leitões os melhores eles eram
vendidos a quem hoje o animal um cavalo
um bom e um animal assim então ele tinha
essa seleção ele era muito criterioso e
era muito minucioso era tudo muito
limpinho tinha era tudo muito programado
e eu convivi
nesse ambiente de tudo muito organizado
com muita disciplina toda muita ordem as
pessoas que vinham ali pra comprar essas
leitor olhavam com tanto carinho
então eu me que eu cresci ali já começou
e daí teve um certo de que meu pai disse
assim meu deus do céu eu acho que a
porta está comendo leitão ou algum bicho
eu devia ter 16 anos por ali mais ou
menos mas meu pai era tão caprichoso
minha filha aqui ela viu nossa casa
porque eu mostrei todo o nosso trato
todo mundo no caminho pra eles
e ele fez como era amor ele fazia sentir
por escândalos
pra não ter aquele muro para subir na
nossa casa e amanhã principal a tarde
lecionar e o país para lá fora eu tinha
que cuidar dos meus irmãos mais novos
então tá que até a manhã da escola eu
sentava ali naquele pátio e eu ficava
atrás ou só assim ele ficava se pondo o
sol e lá naquele morou ali naquela
montanha na frente o sol ia subindo amor
à sombra na verdade né
as sombrinhas subindo bem nessa noite
quando o pai falou assim o a porta está
comendo acho que os leitão o bicho eu
falei 'pai eu ouvi os porquinhos eles
ficam gritando mesmo eu achei que era de
fome mas às vezes davam os gritos
o river se bem forte estridentes
meu pai falou enquanto que você presta
atenção que o horário mais ou menos
quando o que acontece
imagine uma menina de seis anos eu já
mandei nada né
apesar que eu tinha que cuidar do ser
humano eu sentei aqui já no seguinte lá
fora no pátio fique naquele chão lá fora
cuidando para quando fosse acontecer e
já como eu tinha prestado atenção na
questão da sombra
como é que eu ia dizer pro meu pai que
estava na lavoura não tinha telefone não
tinha assina como jóia agora o pai
chegou à noite em casa eu falei na parte
se você viu wando assim não quando a
sombra chegou na casa do vizinho cauduro
os porquinhos dentário
no dia seguinte o pai lá da lavoura lá
no muro quando antes de chegar à sombra
na casa do vizinho lá eles roubem ele
olhou pra casa
ah eu vou pegar esse bicho e nós ficamos
nem em casa comendo do total do lixo
daí esse bicho até então desculpa esse
bicho que era era uma cobra era uma
cobra gigante
vocês não têm noção eu não sei eu nunca
perguntei por que meu pai faleceu cedo
eu nunca cheguei a perguntar pro meu pai
que cobra que era mas ela era grossa era
manchada
com um bege assim eu sei que meu pai
matou ele esticou ela assim na
estradinha que era da casa que é pra
baixo sim acho que devia ter uns três
metros mais
então se um dia vocês vêem uma cobra
pegar 111 x é uma coisa horrível mas eu
eu jamais aquela época e assim eu me é
eu tenho me sentir responsável por
aquilo porque eu escutava eu eu fiquei
ligado fiquei preocupada então eu fui
assim desde pequena se eu já entendi que
tinha que ter essa responsabilidade que
eu tinha que tá apresento como é que na
minha visão de mundo imagina eu nessa
idade eu já vi que o tinha que cuidar
que eu só estava lá mas a impressão que
eu tinha na verdade que depois daquela
montanha não tinha mais nada
tanto pela minha frente quanto nas
minhas costas que o mundo terminava ali
que quando o sol descia na minhas costas
ele tinha ido embora não existia mais
mundo era essa a minha visão
mas eu sabia que eu tinha que cuidar do
ser humano eu tinha que estar ligada
porque a mãe estava na escola para
estava na lavoura isso com seis anos
então por isso que eu acho que deus vai
preparando a gente por favor
daí saímos daqui com nove anos eu for
nós fomos pra campinas do sul e lá é
tinha o meu pai saiu dessa área de de
suínos ele comprou thera ea gente
começou a mexer com lavoura é plantar
soja milho trigo como é que a nossa
região é tem o hábito de plantar
daí o que acontece daí pra mim e da da
lavoura e da vida da linha da linha nova
e até na escola no primário para
terminar a gente andava um quilômetro e
meio mais ou menos mas ali foi um
período tranqüilo
daí do primário próprio ginásio a gente
teve que fazer quem tem mais aqui
ninguém tem mais idade que eu mas na
época é a gente tinha que fazer esse
exame de admissão vocês conseguem
imaginar se imagina do primário ginásio
que fazer exame de admissão é como fazer
vestibular
então eu fiz o exame de admissão tinha
12 anos mas eu não pude continuar porque
eu não tinha idade
hoje as escolas não podem reprovar um
aluno porque o pólo fica com problemas
né
na época eu passei mas eu não pude dar
seqüência porque eu não tinha dado então
não tem como são as coisas diferentes no
mundo mas eu passei no ginásio mas nessa
nessa vila linha era um quilômetro eu
num não tinha ginásio tinha que caminha
oito quilômetros e meio era 17 da vilã
até no município que se eu fosse aqui
não dá pra ver
mas tem um trás e já da quinta melhor
que se vocês vêem aqui o som sete
quilômetros então todo dia de manhã por
três anos
eu fazia esse trajeto eu levantava às
cinco da manhã
as estrelas no céu eu tinha que tá sete
horas no ginásio isso todos os dias lá
no rio grande vem ao meio-dia bate o
sino na matriz nossa senhora do ginásio
ea pá para casa já em casa duas da tarde
então isso foi um período que eu acho
que pra mim eu aprendi a ter coragem
porque tinha épocas que eu tinha que
passar por um ato e cedo de manhã ainda
tinha luas a lua e você andando é a lua
de fazia sombra eu achava que era alguém
que estava me seguindo meu deus meu
coração subia pela boca e tanto medo mas
então o medo a gente corre tem coragem
enfrenta e as estrelas às vezes eu
andava e ficava olhando eu falei meu
deus eu tenho que me apresentar assim
não chega atrasada e esse mato acontecia
que tinha barulho porque os bichinhos
começava a acordar de madrugada e não
sabia se era taquara será bicho que quer
eu corri aqui uma certa trégua eu perdi
as pernas quase então assim esse período
do ginásio foi assim um período que vou
que eu tive que ter assim é muita
disciplina muita coragem para enfrentar
em então foi um período que o que eu
tive que caminha muito bem quando
terminei o ginásio
é nesse período aliança eu também tinha
eu não conseguia ficar parada muito
surgiu o curso de corte e costura foi
fazer nas férias
daí ascar o que as cargas car é como
fosse a capa no paraná hoje em matéria
nem a emater ela tem na verdade a carta
que são mais ou menos do mesmo setor que
a emater hoje ela ela está se sobrepondo
a como fosse acabar a ascar lá eles
faziam um trabalho de extensão rural
projovem então tinha é o clube 4s os
jovens iam lá eles ensinavam projetos
via o que você queria fazer
então na época pensei 'não eu vou fazer
um projeto de a melhor porta
daí eu pensei assim eu ia no no ginásio
né
estava indo o ginásio voltando estava
continuam nessa vida e tinha feito curso
com a costura e foi fazer esse projeto
da horta não tinha começado mal o
magistério mas foi quase no começo do
magistério e daí foi feito esse concurso
acho que você pode passar disso e nesse
concurso nós ganhamos a melhor porta
então vocês conseguem imaginar a vanda
lá no interior
querendo fazer a melhor porta da
localidade da fila mas eu me empenhava
ali tem uma coisa que meu pai me ensinou
desde pequena
não importa o tão grande ou pequeno você
for fazer pode ser o menorzinho mas faça
bem feito faça uma vez não repita esse
eu sempre levava comigo
faça uma vez só então nós fizemos a
melhor porta
daí depois disso aqui eu conhecia mas
terminamos a horta foi fechou ano eu
comecei a fazer magistério quando
terminamos começando magistério de
faltava professor
daí da lida da casa eu ea um quilômetro
e meio pra dar aula
a escola municipal que era uma escolinha
que tinha quatro séries a primeira
segunda terça e quarta série
então pela manhã eu fazia isso de
bicicleta e à tarde então agora já tinha
ônibus pra mim e da vila até lá em
campinas
então de manhã e ia de bicicleta na
escola eu era diretor a professora era
zelador era tudo ali
gente vocês não têm noção o medo o
primeiro dia que eu tinha que fazer
reunião com os pais
como é que era eu e na secretaria da
educação lá em campinas e fazer um
planejamento o plano de ensino
então vocês conseguem imaginar uma
menina de 16 17 18 anos fazendo essas
coisas mas assim o momento pra mim era
desafio tinham medo como eu tive um medo
que eu falei pra já que aqui pra chegar
aqui é o desconhecido a gente fica
conhecimento mas a gente não pode fazer
com que ele nos freia então é eu sempre
pensei em fazer o melhor porque meu pai
sempre disse faça o melhor
faça não importa onde você estiver daí é
ter metade tinha terminado já mais da
metade do magistério veio uma tia da
minha mãe lá visitá la no rio grande ela
disse
aí eu abri uma loja lá em palotina de
roupas mas eu gostaria que eu fosse
trabalhar comigo eu falei não mas então
eu tenho que nas férias com ele na
secretaria da educação vê uma professora
que me pode responsabilidade é minha eu
tenho que colocar uma substituta na
minha escola
depois eu eu vou sim se a mãe eo pai me
permitiu vôo
aí deu tudo certo acabei indo lá nas
férias de julho lá pra palotina
meus pais ficaram lá depois eles
acabaram vindo pra palotina também mas
eu não gostei de serviço de ficar
trabalhando no balcão ali na e eu fui
procurar serviço me fiz é entrevista em
dois lugares no banco quero esse banco
bance ao e foi fazer há também uma
cooperativa agrícola a passar 12 dias me
chamaram nesse banco nesse banco bance
ao esse banco mundial só vocês terem uma
idéia no passado porque senão
ele é muito antigo e eu que nem eu tô
com 63 anos então fica difícil banco pan
se a olheira banco comercial do paraná
quem comprou o banco parcial o banco
comercial do paraná foi o bamerindus
quem comprovar - favorece quem comprou
sbc é o prático então vocês têm a idéia
da na dinâmica de vida de como foi as
coisas nesse banco no dois dias depois
me chamar eu comecei como atendente como
um banco normal e ali conversando com um
direcionado aquela coisa toda toda feliz
da vida né
ana dois dias não vagão caixa você vai
por caixa
cavando ela poucas e dem sabe como é que
o serviço de caxito a aliviar um pouco o
gerente chegou ao empate fez o que acho
que essa coisa toda a gente parece que
não era muito a minha praia como disney
e naquilo saiu o o resultado da do teste
que eu tinha feito na cooperativa
eu falei pô chave e agora eu acho que lá
eu me dou melhor nem porque eu conhecia
do agronegócio eu morava não na roça eu
pensei eu vou lá eu vou me sair bem eu
vou gostar de trabalhar lá fui conversar
com jango que na época era o gerente
falei olha saiu mas eu vou experimentar
las isso voltará a vaga eu volto aqui no
futuro fala não anda tudo bem então
também fui e lá me dei bem gostei e
comecei como recepcionista secretária ea
coisa foi subindo e chegou num
determinado momento que essa foto aqui
que eu já cheguei na área de grande
comercialização de grãos então que que
era aqui tinha uma sala que era eu e
mais uma pessoa o senhor lá que
trabalhava e nós só telefone era só
telefone e não tinha como hoje nem você
não tem tinha internet essas coisas nada
né
então você ligar para são paulo falava
na corretora
e você ligar pra perceber como é que
abriu o chicago como estava de manha
abertura como é que foi o fechamento é
como tava dólar a vamos vender e x nem
contrato vamos comprar tanto era sólida
mas será emocionante
e tem uma coisa que vocês não têm idéia
a gente torcia para que o mercado
supermercado tem aquela coisa simples
não tem ideia como é que só lhe é
vibrante
você vive aquilo lá eu gostava de sulle
e isso eu tive que aprender novo porque
eu não tinha idéia de como é que querem
sinto uma vontade imensa de crescer de
aprender então é dali eu casei me
casando pode passar outra por favor
obrigado casando eu estava ali na loja
tinha toda aquela energia aquela vontade
mas eu falei eu tive eu tive que me
polícia teve que começar nem frear
porque eu tive que sair da cooperativa
porque o meu marido e na verdade era
concorrente da idéia da cooperativa vai
emitir sair não podia continuar
daí o que acontece ali eu viajava com
ele a gente ia para são paulo comprova
semente é tinha congresso em congresso
mas eu não ficava na empresa com ele eu
ficava sempre pouco dizer sim por trás
dos bastidores
vieram os filhos acompanhando os filhos
e assim então eu passei esse período do
de casada ali com os filhos em casa é
sempre mais por detrás dos bastidores eu
num não ficava diretamente na empresa
mas eu nunca parei de me envolver
tinha que fazer treinamento dos
funcionários da empresa eu estava lá eu
ia ver o que tinha que ser treinado qual
a área que a gente tinha que treinar com
quem a gente é buscar qual o
profissional que a gente fosse buscar
então é porque eu tava lá no dia a dia
eu tinha a presença eu estava sempre
presente mas por trás
tanto é que eu não aparecia muito e
quando meu marido adoeceu
as pessoas achavam que eu não ia dar
conta do recado
então nessa fase que os que eu fiquei
ali meio afastada é eu fui aprendendo
foi fazendo o curso eu não parava
não é que eu estava fora do mercado por
favor da ige já os filhos tivessem
quando saíram né que já tinham passou
essa fase
meus filhos foram para curitiba foi
estudando e eu fiquei ali já estava indo
mais na empresa e nenhum
dia tinha problema de um moinho e o
pessoal falou olha nós temos que assumir
aquele moinho de trigo porque eles não
conseguem pagar a conta é o seu que não
tem ninguém que entende de moinho de
trigo
eu falei não era então eu eu pego isso
aqui gente eu não entendia nada
eu não entendia só saber se comprar
farinha no mercado
então eu não sabia que tipo de grão eu
não sabia o que era um lanche ter com o
que não significa farina eu não sabia
andar eu não sabia nada então eu tinha
que buscar marketing que busca é
registrar a marca tinha que fazer
projeto da vigilância sanitário eu tinha
que ver tudo
então aquele mergulho de cabeça
o homem era pequeno era um cunho
comercial mas a minha cabeça de novo
wanda faça o melhor então mergulhei de
cabeça dois anos depois que o aço neste
manhã
tanto é que nós ganhamos o prêmio mas
somos em são paulo a melhor farinha da
américa latina
então nós estávamos concorrendo com quem
quando a conta com o sol como sei que
então não importa a gente tem que ter
humildade a lição que eu tiro digo de de
dessa fase é que eu tinha que ter
humildade de questionar de perguntar
como é que vai
tinha que ter dedicação eu tinha que ter
persistência né e de novo fazer o melhor
então mesmo que ele fosse pequeno não
era comparado com uma banca com qualquer
outro meio grande gigante que por em
curitiba curitibanos que a gente ia era
pequeno mas eu queria fazer o melhor e
sem querer ter a glória quero receber um
prêmio não eu não estava preocupado em
receber e eu nem sabia que tinha essa
pretensão mas a gente recebeu então mais
uma lição tão vamos lá a horta é meu pai
primeiro com os porquinhos aorta
isso vem logo na sequência
nós tivemos nós tínhamos concessionárias
mas nas concessionárias sempre tinha
executivos que cuidavam ou era um
pessoal da fábrica sempre alguém de fora
daí ano uma uma visita que o regional da
fiat pediu para a gente lá eu na minha
cabeça era irá discutir um plano de ação
com as coisas todas de fábrica
eles falaram na nossa reunião em breve
rápida
nós vamos é ser bem objetivos nós
queremos que quem vá administrar as
concessionárias gravando
nós não queremos mais executivos bom a
gente voltou de curitiba reunião foi nem
meia hora chegam em casa e disse você
vai vai assumir esse negócio
niltinho não gostando muito mais e não
sei se não estava confiando que
aconteceu mas falei não vou sim a gente
era uma alguém pra por lá no ruim né
a gente põe alguém no moinho e eu assumo
a aas concessionários gente de
concessionária não entende de novo nada
se consegue entender você sai do moinho
e por uma concessionária que você tem
que ter relacionamento com fábrica
você não sabe que é uma porção sbd é
imediata é tanto os termos é tanta coisa
que vocês não têm idéia então o que
aconteceu passar um período sim obrigado
então passou o período que a gente foi o
que recebeu a obra já estava vindo junto
comigo ea gente conseguiu também mais
uma vez hoje a gente é referência
praticamente mundial
eu só tô esgotando o meu tempo né me
emociono em pó vem rapidinho ali que a
gente insere
então tá nem o que meu marido ficou
doente
nessa faixa que foi a fase mais difícil
da minha vida porque na verdade eu tinha
que cuidar dos filhos trazem no mercado
é acompanhar ele o mercado e é ingrato
porque todo mundo quer te cobra e quando
você está fragilizado as pessoas querem
absorvi querem tomar o espaço de onde
você está
então eu e pra mim é mais difícil por
favor
na sequência disso eu falei não dá pra
nós continuarmos em palotina a gente
precisa se estruturar na questão da
logística é a a a fazer uma sede
administrativa para toda a gente mudou
para cascavel
em 2012 nós mudamos pra cá daqui depois
estava tudo estruturado eu falei não
agora eu vou fazer uma graduação
isso depois de tudo isso eu ainda tirava
tempo para virar ontem eu venho aqui no
funk eu venho aqui na faixa avisar toda
noite eu tô aqui toda noite eu corro que
nem um maluco mas eu venho aqui no curso
de direito eu estou no sétimo período
então é um prazer para mim poder
aprender eu aprendo com os professores
eu aprendi com os alunos a instituição é
maravilhosa professores bons eu disse
não eu me realizo aqui pra mim é a minha
terapia apesar que tem dias que eu vou
embora chorando de tristeza porque eu
não consigo tirar uma nota boa porque
não consigo estudar não dá tempo então
eu fico triste se eu chorando embora pra
casa da minha filha de mãe deixa isso
aqui é assim mesmo após a mãe se
recupera
então é assim a vida é assim eu só
queria mais só finalizando ali eu queria
dizer é pra vocês que com tudo isso eu
aprendi que deus
ele tem um plano para cada um de nós que
o tempo ele vai vocês perceberam como
ele foi moldando ele foi metralhado
então acho que a gente só acontece com a
gente
a gente tem que aprender a confiar que a
jornada da gente mesmo a gente não
consegue entender o que está acontecendo
mas siga em frente que o sofrimento
vocês viram a gente sofre de toda
maneira as dificuldades a dor a falta de
alguma coisa
isso tudo é um aprendizado é faça sempre
o melhor
não importa onde e como isso é aquilo
sempre trago meu pai tudo que você for
fazer não importa onde o que qual é o
teu negócio mergulho de cabeça faça com
amor com vontade tem que ter coragem
essa coragem desde lado sempre a gente
sempre tem que ter essa coragem de a
frente não se deixem levar pelo medo
vocês pensam que pra mim vir aqui na fag
depois de 40 anos longe de uma de um
banco escolar você encarar esses meninos
saindo tudo turbinado era fácil
então eu penso e o tempo gente isso
ninguém presta atenção no tempo o nosso
tempo é limitado nós temos prazo de
validade em que nasci p'ra etapa embora
vá embora então a priorize pegue e
faça-o ser bem no seu tempo não fica a
dispersão do tempo pelo amor de deus a
liderança ela vem a gente vai
trabalhando ela desde criança ela não
imposta
você vai construindo então quem pensa
que a eu quero ser gente não é assim
você não sobe de elevador
você tem que subir de escada você vai
construindo né e você precisa melhorar
todo dia a gente se eu digo pra vocês
bem rapidamente que eu fui alfabetizada
com a lusa sabe que a lousa lousa e hoje
eu tenho que está evoluindo junto com
toda essa tecnologia então é possível
claro que é só querer porque eu poderia
ter ficado atrás né então e agradeça
agradeço agradeço agradeço todo dia se
está vivo que você conseguiu assim
sofreu se não deu hoje a minha vai dar
certo a gente esquece de agradecer então
agradeça que você pode caminhar que está
respirando que você tá podendo como é
que você vai dormir
agradeço que se tem um teto que você tem
pessoas contigo
então eu agradeço vocês agradeço o riff
já que todas vocês brigada minha família
meus filhos tudo ligado
[Aplausos]